thank you very much for the introduction
Simon
um yeah Welcome to our talk about
bringing NLP models to production and I
know it has been a long conference I'm
very proud of you that you're here
despite the social event yesterday
despite lunch break and probably
information overload we try to not
overload you after lunch break so please
stay with us stay awake and
um yeah I'm looking forward to the talk
so we've brought you some of our yeah
real life NLP use cases and where we
faced some obstacles some issues also do
you um due to requirements change and
yeah this topic will focus on how we
dealt with these obstacles which ways we
use to to overcome those
um that's why we will first start with a
journey to NLP Ops I don't know if this
is even a term if not
I invented it yesterday so
um first the journey then we have our
two use cases shortly described and then
we have a short checklist you can take
away and use for every other probably
every other machine learning project
um yeah NLP projects
um of course as well
so
um
let us introduce ourselves first so I'm
Larissa I'm a senior data scientist at
Savannah Aggie
um if you want to chat with me
afterwards you can also talk to me about
science fiction or playing round net I
will also be happy to talk about that
yeah hi my name is Jonathan I'm also
working at savanta now since one year
before that I studied physics again if
you are interested in the sports called
Jugger or if you want to talk about the
board game terraforming mask then then
also I'm the go-to guy yeah some known
people
all right so let's start first with
maybe some boric boring topic um so what
does our company do but this is
important maybe to understand some
deployment decisions we took so we're
working at savanta which is yeah
basically user experience company so we
started to do good user experience for
sap and then developed other yeah
experience fields around it such as
chatbots AI assistants and also machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
therefore a short disclaimer so we are
talking maybe about sap Solutions but
the
yeah the implications of those
deployment decisions you could also draw
them on other deployment
um yeah platforms as they are also open
source so you yeah this is not
exclusively sap related
um and even though we are an sap partner
we're not paid for this talk so yeah
these are our experiences and we want to
to give them to you so maybe you can do
maybe better decisions or other
decisions than we did and yes this is
not necessarily best practices but
um yeah we want to give you our
experiences so you can learn from that
so why
we wanted to do this talk
um when I started working at savanta
back in 2018
um the latest or the the hottest topic
were bird models and Elmo and stuff so
this was really in the beginning and as
you can see in NLP the yeah the
development of
model sizes was really quick I mean
every some months there is a new a new
model with new cool features and this is
why we should yeah talk or think about
model deployment in NLP especially I
mean this is a case for other
machine learning models as well but in
NLP they the models are getting real big
really quickly so um yeah this is an
important topic
um and even though I'm not I don't want
to deploy for example chat gbt by myself
but even like for small applications NLP
models can get really big
and this
can lead to problems at the deployment
in the end
um
so our goal is you is to make you aware
of the following during your NLP Journey
which roughly consists of those points
and you will do or you will make a lot
of decisions that will impact the
deployment options later
so during our talk we will have a
checklist oriented on this journey to
NLP Ops and with this checklist you can
have a look if you considered everything
that you need to decide your deployment
so when you start with a use case you're
probably thinking about okay what is
what are we talking about what's the
problem I want to solve will it be a
service will it be a testing front end
will it be a multi-language model or
everything together so this will this
can have implications
um later on you will do maybe
brainstorming
um what tools do I have at hand
um which restrictions do I have do I
have certain deployment limitations and
what are my possibilities in general
and um as Next Step you will maybe
gather requirements
do I need a regular retraining
how fast does my model need to respond
do I need to fit in some company
standards or do I fit do I have to fit
in some existing company infrastructure
then as the next step you will get some
data so how is your data look like do
you need data augmentation do you need
certain pre-processing steps that you
also need to transfer
um all you need to do later during
inference
and as last step you will train a model
but what kind of model will it be will
it be like a plain NLP model using TF
IDF will it be a hugging phase
Transformer model can you apply some
pruning at the end so these are
questions and then you can start with
deployment right
yes but that's part of the truth but
during because during those questions
and during those answers that you you
gave yourself to those questions you
already decided part of your
yeah decision about the deployment
because all those decisions influence
your your deployment options
in this checklist it's not complete but
it might help you to ask the right
questions in your journey
I will not go through each and every
point in detail you will see that in the
use cases and we've also added an
explanation about those checklists in
the appendix so you can later on
download the slides and have a look at
it
and important is there is no rule like
if this then that so I don't know if I
use TF IDF I can deploy everywhere so
maybe that could be true I don't know
but
um you could only collect pros and cons
you will always have to balance and
there will never be a clear decision
okay this is what I have to use take
this more as a guideline
so let's start with the first use case
um I call it here product search and
this is exactly what it does
um it is a feature for a chatbot
interface where you can for example the
user can type in I want to buy vegan
pizza
so through the stat interface we have a
wrapper service and our NLP service is
called
um to yeah to extract the important
information we want to have from the
sentence in this case vegan as a
property and pizza as a product the
property describing the product
from the NLP service we apply this and
then we search in the database if we
have vegan pizzas in our database and we
reply with the options so this is
roughly the use case
um how we started to deploy this or to
to work on this we had a Spacey model it
was one language it was German it worked
really well and we deployed it on cloud
Foundry I don't know how many of you are
familiar with Cloud Foundry it's an open
source Cloud application platform
yeah maybe similar to to kubernetes but
it takes yeah it gives you
it supports you a little bit more on the
infrastructure side than for example
standard kubernetes and you can upload
also they are not called images they're
called the droplets are starting on that
platform which you can build with build
packs which are all available for other
languages in this case Cloud Foundry was
self-hosted by the by the customer we
worked for so this was yeah the the
solution we went
um the drawbacks here Cloud Foundry
comes with an upload limitation of one
gigabyte which includes all files also
the model in this case and all
dependencies which will be a problem you
will see in a minute
and we had like four gigabytes of disk
space limitation which was also kind of
critical later on
so the model worked it was really nice
for the customer they really liked it
and they said okay
let's do this in 10 other languages
let's do this even better because we
have no training data for you okay so
maybe Spacey is not an option anymore
because we cannot fine tune our models
in this extent we needed it
um so we switched to Transformer model
um yeah where the fine tuning it was a
little bit better to do
um and we had a wider option of language
choices because the customer was really
creative about Which languages they
wanted to use
um Hungarian one of them
so the size of dependency is really
exploded we had to rely on on tensorflow
and this just exploded our one gigabyte
upload limit
and also the running perspective changed
so we yeah Grew From A POC stage to uh
yeah running in productive for several
years stage
so Cloud Foundry was not an option for
us anymore we had the luck that the
customer also had an
um yeah an Azure stack at hand so we
switched to container instances
um
which is maybe a smaller version you
could say like a kubernetes cluster it's
just yeah singular containers
um running independent of each other so
we could
um yeah deploy our services there and we
deployed single services for single
languages so all of them running in
parallel in two stages
um deaf and prod
um the advantages we can really easily
start new container instances we don't
have to think about okay do they have to
be managed in a cluster
um this gets completely complicated
um
so this was really easy and the
deployment was also a little bit easier
because I mean Docker is a little bit
more familiar for us than Cloud Foundry
which is also easy but not as familiar
for us
the drawbacks are you need
somehow to build your Docker images you
need an infrastructure around it to host
your your images maybe in a registry you
have to have maybe in the ICD pipeline
so this overhead we had then
additionally to the POC solution
so this was the first use case where we
had
problems due to the
um due to the model size
Jonathan will now talk about the Second
Use cases a second use case where we
Face similar issues but resolve them in
a different way
yeah thanks
um yeah the Second Use case is now not
about named entity recognition but it's
all about text classification
um in this case we already had an
existing applications where users can
analyze different events and now a new
requirement was that these events should
be classified in to one of two
categories based on text information so
in this example there would be an event
with a text called uh that that reads no
error was detected with the device which
then should be classified as being not
relevant for this analysis and maybe a
different text in German that would read
the sensor cable is broken which would
indicate that it's actually a relevant
event
um
the users would rely on these these
classifications but it's not so much
that they actually requested them on
demand when they they were listing
events it's rather that in a nightly
schedule the wrapper service would call
the model look for new text in the
database and do these predictions write
them back to the database and then the
user can just look at them when doing
their analysis
um
yeah you can already see in this use
case we started with two languages
German and English and we were building
one pipeline for each language
um based on a just a simple plain NLP
model how we called it which in this
case means that we used a TF IDF
vectorizer Then followed by by a
classifier to do the job which also
worked really great for these languages
that we had at hand
um yeah in terms of the dependencies
that also means we are quite small it's
like around 300 megabytes so we are
using scikit-learn and pandas but that
is this is no problem to again deployed
on cloud Foundry
um
it's very important in in this case we
had this already existing application
and now the machine learning model was
an add-on and a new feature to this
application and this application was
already running on a cloud Foundry
instance
um this time it's hosted on the
so-called sap business technology
platform which is just a cloud platform
provided by sap where businesses can
develop and also deploy applications and
yeah they offer a lot of additional
services like database management and
for example also a cloud Foundry runtime
where you can deploy applications
um
yeah and as the the main application was
running on cloud Foundry it was
quite or
yeah the choice was obvious to try at
least and uh deploy the model there as
well
um so that we have an easy communication
um between the application and the model
itself
um
yeah the the configuration on on the
business technology platform is a little
bit similar uh a little bit different
now the these app uh upload limit is 1.5
gigabytes
um but as I said with this 300 megabytes
um of dependencies that that's not a
problem for us and also the disk space
and memory allocation that you can use
for single instances that are running on
cloud Foundry
um doesn't pose a problem for for this
kind of small model that we were
deploying in this case
um yeah and the story is similar to the
first use case the customer was quite
happy with the model so of course we
should extend it in this case to all
languages that these events
um can occur in which are more than 20
for for this use case
um
and of course we don't have sufficient
training data in all of these languages
so the option of just building a
pipeline per language that we can deploy
is not really an option
um again instead we use the Transformer
model from hugging phase
um specifically the digital bird
multilingual model
um that was able to cover all the
languages we needed
um
yeah we use specifically the tensorflow
implementation for the training um which
also means that our dependencies get
quite large similar to the first use
case you can already imagine that this
will lead to to some problems with the
cloud Foundry environment as it was
before
um
so the preferred solution
that you could imagine for such a larger
model would be the effect to to use like
a dedicated AI runtime where you maybe
also have GPU resources available
that can scale according to to the
request that you send to your model
um and in case of the business
technology platform there is such a
service available it's called the sap AI
Core
um
so quite nice
but for our specific use case with this
customer we didn't have this available
so again we needed to
make work with make you with with what
we had meaning trying to somehow fit
this now large model still on this Cloud
Foundry
instance and Cloud Foundry runtime
yeah and as you see the
two major limitations are this app size
during upload with our dependencies we
break it with with the model size we
break it so we somehow have to get
around that
um yeah just let me just quickly explain
our workarounds for one you can just
save your model in an external block
storage and then just later on download
it to the application
um so there's no need to push it with
the application code itself just have it
saved in an external storage
um
and for the other facts that the model
that the dependencies are too large
um
we opted to use onnx which stands for
open neural network exchange and it
defines a format how you can save your
machine learning models in a framework
independent way
so by
saving our model from the tensorflow
implementation of the neural network to
onnx we can just get rid of this
complete dependency and then later on
during inference we just need the onnx
runtime package which is uh much smaller
as a dependency
in case if you want to learn more about
onnx I think there was a talk on Monday
um that and they really went into uh
detail about when an X also how to
explain how you can
convert your own models or
transformations to to nnx
yeah so with these two changes the app
size limit was not a problem anymore we
we could just upload our
application that was hosting the model
um
but the second thing of course is that
Transformer models tend to like to use a
lot of memory during predictions
and as I said before on cloud Foundry
with this eight gigabytes limitation to
only also CPU memory this can lead to
problems if you try to do large batch
classifications
um yeah so in our case we just limited
how much the model can predict at the
same time
um this of course leads to larger
response times of your model
um but as we had these mainly scheduled
scans that run overnight and this was
not a concern for us um because if it's
just running overnight it doesn't make a
difference if it's 15 minutes or an hour
at least for for this specific
application
um
yeah so this concludes then our Second
Use case
um in this case the changing
requirements didn't lead us to a
different deployment option or different
deployment infrastructure we rather
implemented some some work arounds to
make do with the infrastructure that we
already had
um
and now to to conclude all of this and
what we try to to convey you as a
message of this talk
um
when you develop a model
you always should think about your goal
with the model uh from the beginning
like how will you later on serve the
model and what requirements does this
bring with you
um yeah and we developed this kind of
checklist the NLP Ops checklist
um that you can use as a guideline
um which defines some different topics
that you can think about and if you
clarify all your options and
restrictions regarding these different
checklist items this can guide you to
the different deployment options that
you you will have available for yourself
um yeah we just covered the the two in
this use case but of course there are
many more providers of cloud
infrastructure
that each come with their their
different advantages and disadvantages
for some of these checklist items
um yeah and you just have have a look
around what's available there
um it's also important make yourself
familiar with the condensing mechanisms
that work for your model so before
saying uh well I have this new model so
now I have to change all my
infrastructure maybe have a look can you
simplify your model or condense it a
little bit to make work with what you
have
so for example in the Second Use case we
use the Transformer model from hugging
phase but we already used the distilled
word version which is just a smaller
version of the bird language models
um so maybe there's also an option that
you just can can make a model itself
smaller
yeah and uh again as a last point
take all of this as a guideline because
there is no true answer
um
the main thing that we want to to tell
you is that have a look at all these
restrictions and and think about them
also during your model development
because decisions that you make during
development of the model itself can also
lead to or restrict yourself in the
choice of uh deployment options that you
have available
yeah and with that we want to thank you
all for your attention
um we hope you learned something or at
least found it somewhat entertaining and
if you have any questions we are happy
to answer them
[Applause]
thank you so much for what I found was a
very very interesting talk and I seem to
be not the only person because there are
quite some questions for you
um just a gentle reminder you can vote
on these questions I only have one vote
here and five questions use the
opportunity you have
um question number one would be how and
where do you train the models and where
did your data reside
so
um this is I think different for both
use cases in my use case
um we train so we experiment locally and
then we have our own machine learning
server where we train and share models
and data so it's an internal self-hosted
server which we can use to train the
models
yeah and for the topic of where the data
resides
um so for example in the Second Use case
um this business technology platform
also has a database layer where the
customer has all their data stored
um but we can also access that locally
so when we're trying to to train the
model then we can do that locally or
from our server access the data from
there and then later on in Productions
it's just directly used In This Cloud
platform
and then there seems to be an interest
in how you monitor your services and the
deployed models
yeah I can start so um
again for this business technology
platform there are they are already
provided services that you can use to to
monitor your model
um
and in addition to that
at least for the
like the evaluation of the model itself
um I was just training them locally on
on the server and
um yeah there we had also some just
metric is there so there was no
automatic retraining that we had to
Monitor and specifically I don't know if
you want to yes sorry yeah we also had
no no retraining we had to monitor we on
cloud Foundry we use the built-in
um grafana stack so it comes
automatically with the grafana stack
that monitors all your applications
um on Azure we actually implemented
additional endpoints and then also
included them into our own
um yeah kafana dashboard so it's
comes additionally on top and this is
why also
um on this slide monitoring security is
also a factor that you can look at when
you yeah think about your deployment
options because some of the deployment
options come already with a little bit
more support in regards to monitoring
for example
okay then the next upmost question is
how large was was the onx version of
your application
um so I think after converting the model
to own an X it was like 400 megabytes
large yeah
um but we just converted the model
itself and not the rest of the pipelines
so for that we still needed the
dependencies
and there seems to be a general interest
in on X related questions here
um did you have to do a lot of O and X
coding or did it come out of the box for
the hugging phase Transformer yeah for
hugging phase uh it comes out of the box
um or in in our case we actually use the
tensorflow tool and X
package to Lulu conversion but I didn't
write any of when X converters myself or
so I I was listening to them in the in
the talk on Monday and I'm now very
interested in and want to try them but
uh yeah we didn't have to do anything
that that came out of the box oh well
that's convenient yeah maybe just to add
so if you are interested in this when
the next conversions
um I found very good tutorials on
hugging face that explain everything
that you have to do there so you can
have a look yourself there
and I think we have time for one last
question
do you have any requirements regarding
latency or throughput and if so how did
you make sure you can fulfill them
yeah so I think it's also maybe it's
also there in the list
um
so yeah we had we had some requirements
about that
um we also needed to experiment a little
bit with the size of workers we can
start in our runtime so this is where we
can where we could handle some of these
requirements
um it's a little so I think it's a
little bit easier to do this on the
Azure side because you have more
um yeah more freedom about scalability
there I don't know what yeah so for the
Second Use case we didn't have any
requirements but I know that on cloud
Foundry it's quite easily quite easy to
to scale horizontally so just start
several instances of your application
and the load balancing will be done
automatically
um and then for the vertical scaling of
instances you can only do that by
redeploying them and then you have also
these limitations of eight gigabytes of
memory so that's not really the option
but horizontally is fine yeah
thank you so much I have three more open
questions but I guess you will be
hanging around for a moment so people
can approach you yeah for sure
thanks once more
thank you